Okay. Now one thing to note here is we have our radio buttons
and how is the user to know which is which?
They're just 3 anonymous radio buttons.
Well, that is what the element is for,
and I'll show you how to use that in our Editor.
So to give the user a sense of what they're clicking on,
rather than just clicking on random dots,
we're going to use the element--and it looks something like this.
I'll add the element to each of these inputs.
So I've added one element.
The elements stay the same for this first one.
I wrapped it in a element that also has the text, "One" in it.
This will cause the word "One" to appear next to the radio button.
I'll go ahead and add it on these other two as well.
Okay. So I surrounded our other two s with a element.
I added some line breaks in here
so it's a little bit easier to read,
but all that's really changed is I've added
opening , a closing , and then some text to each one of these.
Let's see how this looks in the browser.
When I load this in the browser, now we can see
the labels before our radio buttons.
And so when I select one of them--"One", "Two", "Three"--
that makes it easier so the user can see what they're actually doing.
You know--you give the radio buttons a label.
And when I click Submit, as we expected:
q-three in the URL.
Now, of course, the label doesn't have to match the value of the radio button
but, generally, they're closely related.